kommt zur aktuellen sitzung zur letzten
sitzung in diesem semester die
abschlusssitzung was haben wir heute vor
es soll jetzt ihr es darum gehen doch
mal die vergangenen sitzung aufzuzeigen
was da wichtig war ganz kurz überblicks
haffter sie doch mal guten überblick
bekommen dann werden wir die
diskussionen über gehen und noch mal
intern offene fragen diskutieren die
übriggeblieben sind im laufe dieses
semesters und am ende gibt es auch die
möglichkeit über hausarbeiten zu reden
und einige vorschläge werde ich auch
noch machen
so jetzt aber gleich zur überblick und
zwar möchte ich jetzt jede sitzung die
wir diesem semester hatten dass man also
doch deutlich über zehn sitzungen die
möchte ich alle jetzt ihm noch mal ganz
kurz präsentieren dass sie hier noch mal
ja so einen einblick bekommen und sich
auch noch anregen lassen können für
mögliche hause weiß themen also die
erste sitzung war der frage gewidmet was
sind emotionen und da hatte ich ja so
ein schlimmer entwickelt mittlerweile
habe ich ja auch eine schöne diagonal
strichen bekommen und diese kategorien
zu trennen ist immer noch vorläufig zu
verstehen ich bin nach wie vor der
überzeugung dass wir hier etwas anfangen
können
wir haben jetzt gesehen emotionen sind
solche phänomene wie liebe hass achtung
das sind zumindest nach meiner theorie
klassische emotionen und wir müssen die
unterscheiden von großen gefühlen wie
hunger schmerz die immer ein bisschen
äußerlich sind und die auch irgendwie
nicht ganz unsere subjektivität
ausmachen
hier sind im hunger nicht wir selbst
wenn wir es aber sind dann ist der
hunger kein blödes gefühl mehr sondern
emotionen also so möchte es bestimmt ihr
sind wir in der liebe sind wir ganz wir
selbst als individuen auch im hass sind
wir
individuell ganz stark vertreten das hat
eine ganz persönliche note würde ich
jetzt behaupten genau so die liebe die
achtung denke ich auch immanuel kant
würde das bestreiten er würde sagen in
der achtung sind wir gar nicht mehr als
individuum greifbar sind als
persönlichkeit und als persönlichkeit
damit meint er nicht uns als wie die wii
duelle persönlichkeiten sondern als
reine vernunft subjekte dennoch würde
ich auch das was kann unter achtung
zusteht als eine emotion fassen so lust
und mut die können uns ziemlich erfüllen
das sag ich mal auch in der lust und in
der woche können wir als personen
deutlich hervortreten
sie haben etwas von emotionaler qualität
aber sie sind nur momentan fanden sie
fliegen sehr schnell wieder
das heißt da blitzt vielleicht mal
unsere persönlichkeit auf aber sie hat
keine konstanz ich will nichts während
sie trägt nicht perfekte tragen nicht
die blitzen auf und vergehen wieder und
deswegen würde ich sagen das hier nicht
so eine art von identität eine personale
identität erkennbar wird sie wird es
aber wenn die emotionen hier habe ich
jetzt lust und wut die habe ich deswegen
gewählt diese effekte weil sie sehr
schön die emotionen der liebe und des
hauses kontrastieren also man könnte
sagen die lust oder auch die begierde
ist eine effektive form von liebe
emotionen daneben wie die wut auch eine
effektive verkürzte kurz vorm oder
schulstufe ist des hasses dem ozon das
heißt das wer also meine these darüber
können wir nachher noch diskutieren
gerne auch unten im video auf youtube
und stimmungen sind für mich färbungen
die uns gewissermaßen dauerhaft gegeben
sind die ich aber dennoch nicht
individuell erfassen würde sicher nicht
kann man sagen auch trauer
wird ganz ohne emotionen wenn sie höchst
individuell gestaltet wird und wenn sie
auch noch neben diese robustheit hat uns
ganz erfüllt aber mir scheint in der
trauer
also eine färbung vorhanden zu sein wie
auch im glück seine hochstimmung ein
hoch bestimmtheit die aber eben nicht
etwas wie eine einstellung hat und diese
ganz klare fokussierung wie sie eben der
liebe in hass und verachtung vorliegen
also hier scheint mir so ein bisschen
der fokus zu fehlen diese konzentration
hier scheint mir also der allgemeinheit
der befindlichkeit gegeben zu sein
weswegen ich sie auch nicht als integral
bezahlt würde wie es nur die emotionen
sind ist nach wie vor diskussionswürdig
und ich möchte wirklich gerne dafür
plädieren dass nicht als perfekt
vollkommen andere sein als problematisch
darum geht es ja nur als die diskussions
impuls soll das zu verstanden werden so
dass weiten der ersten sitzung der
zweiten haben wir das hier diskutiert
und dann sind noch übergegangen
auch bezüglich der frage war es
emotionen sind zu diesem standort
enzyklopädie artikel emotion der eben
die wie ich finde sehr überzeugende
these vertreten hatte das in der emotion
ein urteil suspect ein phänomenaler
gefühls aspekt und ein kognitiver ein
motivation ahler bewegungs aspekt
antriebs aspekte enthalten ist also
nochmal gefühls das bag urteils als dead
oder kognitiver aspekt und motivation
alias big diese drei aspekte sind die
emotionen enthalten und das finde ich
sehr sehr gut weil es diese komplexität
zeigt die autoren dieses artikels
sprechen auf einem syndrom
wenn ich an einem symptom syndrom also
hier laufen verschiedene strömungen
sammelt seine einheit
diese security kann ich sehr empfehlen
ich verlinke sie auch nach unten noch
ein video
da finden sie wirklich zu fast allen
wichtigen begriffen der philosophie ganz
ganz gut informierte artikel die sie
sehr wohl
ihren können und die auch immer auf dem
laufenden stand gehalten werden
und sie finden auch eine sehr gute
biografie dazu man muss einschränkt dazu
sagen dass diese artikel sehr
angelsächsisch ausgerichtet sind zb
nationale referenzen nicht zu
berücksichtigen in mitteleuropa also
französische literatur deutsche
literatur italienische literatur auch
russischen literatur wird hier nicht so
präsent sein wie eben die angelsächsisch
das muss man einschränkend dazu sagen
dennoch ist das mit die beste kostenlos
frei verfügbare enzyklopädie die ich
kenne ich ihn auch sehr empfehlen für
hausarbeiten und 20 beschäftigung
jetzt haben wir uns dann im zweiten teil
des seminars er mit historischen
auffassungen befasst mitleid war da im
zentrum da hatten wir youtube in seiner
theorie der affekte jung unterscheidet
nicht zu stark zwischen emotionen und
leidenschaften jemand oder auch passions
wie wir es jetzt getan haben und
seminare
hier habe ich diese ganze übersicht noch
mal geben sehr differenziert alle sind
aber in der perfektion also form der
wahrnehmung der innere wahrnehmung und
es sind genau gesagt eindrücke nicht
abstrakte vorstellung und ich glaube
eben das was ihr hier jetzt die durch
indirekt einbildungskraft hervorgerufene
heftige perfekte bezeichnet dass wir das
als emotion bezahlen können vielleicht
auch das hier schon was er jetzt hier
als gefühlsregung bezeichnen könnten die
stimmungen zeichen schönheit
hässlichkeit finde ich passt nicht so
ganz sind jedenfalls will sie qualitäten
gehen wir uns kontemplativ erfassen und
primäre eindrücke die könnte man als
nehmen wie schmerz könne man das gefühl
bezeichnen
als diese reflexiven heftigen und auch
durch einbildungskraft verstärkte
regierung reflektierte perfekte oder
nach jung passions die könnte dann als
emotionen bezeichnet auch interessantes
haus arbeitsthema ein bisschen weitere
orden um in diese ganzen unterscheidung
zu bringen und diese
schienen formen klaffen an damit gut
gewählten beispielen abzugrenzen dann
als nächsten schön als kontrast zu der
vision hatten wir diesen herrn immanuel
kant
da hatten wir die achtung behandelt und
im gegensatz zu der region der die
vernunft als slave sessions bestimmt
hatte als junge ist die vernunft nur
möglichst klar wenn der effekte die
effekte geben uns vor was wir wollen und
gewürgt und tritt in den dienst dieser
effekte und tut das was wir begehren die
sind instrumentellen eine dienerin
im gegensatz dazu ist jeden kannte
auffassung dass die vernunft und gefühl
überlegen ist das also die vernunft die
gefühle beherrscht und die gefühle
gewissermaßen die sklaven der vernunft
gerade umgedreht die vernunft ist die
sklaven die effekte sind wie man ihre
herrscherin diese kontrolliert war diese
überlegenheit der vernunft über die
effekte die gefühle die neigung die zeit
die ich gerade im moralischen gefühle
achtung welches nicht normales gefühl es
keine gewöhnlichen sind ein vernunft
gewirkt das gefühl ein vernünftiges
gefühlen schwierig zu verstehen
ich glaube dass man vernünftiges gefühl
in dieser einheit von gefühl und
vernunft auch von motivation als emotion
fassen kann
weil eben diese achtung wie er sie
beschreibt gefühls aspekt hat wir sind
in der achtung führen wir erhabenheit
aber auch schmerz dieser dopplung dann
am hatte urteils aspekt in der achtung
erkennen wir auch gewisse rast in
moralischen wert urteil und die achtung
ist die moral triebfeder wie kann sagt
sie motiviert uns zur guten handlung
also hier sieht man meines erachtens
sehr gut dass das was kann da ein
vernunft gewirkt das gefühl im grunde
genommen ja gut ja dann haben wir als
nächsten hatten wir dann max scheler
der hatte als philologe gewirkt wendet
sich gegen eine naturalistische
reduktionistischen auffassung des ekels
er möchte ich eben nicht
naturwissenschaftlich bestimmen sondern
philosophisch phänologischer bestimmt
die scham natürlich auch im zusammenhang
mit dem ek als ein selbst gefühl dass
eine selbst beziehung also wieder etwas
reflexiv ist die scham resultiert aus
der spannung von eva individualität und
reflektierte allgemeinheit bzw
objektivität scham ist auch ein schutz
gefühl des individuums gegen das
allgemeine also wir wollen nicht vor das
forum der allgemeinheit gezerrt werden
und zur verletzlichkeit unserer
individualität deswegen ist auch die
chance eine art hülle sein unsichtbares
kleid was unsere körper umgibt nicht nur
unseren körper sondern ihm auch unsere
individualität im abstrakten ziele
natürlich schauen wir uns in gewissen
situation wenn wir in aktien haben wir
schreiben uns eben auch wenn unsere
individualität und löst wird und für die
öffentlichkeit gezerrt wird und wir
können natürlich auch für andere schämen
dass das phänomen des fremdschämens als
nächsten hatten wir den ekel anhand von
job darin diesen existenz philosophen
der ecke wird in seinem roman der
gleichnamige titel bis 138 behandelt
dass es so ein gründungs format des
französischen existenzialismus könnte
man sagen dann hier geht es um die
wurzel eines kastanienbaum es die der
protagonist in einem park betrachtet und
er diese wurzel die lässt ihn die
existenz ganz deutlich fassen die
existenz ist für ihn nichts abstraktes
wie bekannt kein abstraktes prädikat
sondern ein hoch konkretes phänomen und
existenz wird mit einem mal etwas
problematisches zuerst als etwas
ekelerregende sichtbar und wir müssen
aber auch sehen dass die ekel nur ein
moment ist in diesem erkenntnisprozess
die existenz der es am ende immer um die
absurdität auch geht also ekel und
absurdität nach seite ganz eng
miteinander zusammen
also der die absoluten ist der schlüssel
der existenz der schlüssel seines
wirkens ja also ich hier nicht als
effekt also würgereiz wie man ihn häufig
hatte als emotionen mit einem urteil
suspect mit eine motivation aber eben
ganz stark existenzialistisch gefährt
gesehen dass noch bei weiteren formen
wie der verzweiflung das hören klicken
die verzweiflung ist ein missverhältnis
das selbst und seinen ganz verschiedenen
relationen deswegen ist die verzweiflung
auch eine problematische einstellung
hier sieht man also schon sie hat was
von auch ein urteil suspect jetzt für
unterscheidet verschiedene formen der
verzweiflung und diese letzte
verzweifelt man selbst sein zu wollen
ist die schwierigste dieser
verschiedenen formen und die ganze
debatte über verzweiflung ist bei qi
gong an theologischen kontext
eingebettet die man eben auch immer mit
berücksichtigen muss hier hatten wir im
seminar auch diskutiert inwiefern man
von verzweiflung als einer affektiven
störung sprechen kann oder auch von
depressionen und wir hatten gesehen dass
man hier immer ein bisschen genauer
unterscheiden muss also es handelt sich
eigentlich bei depression und
verzweiflung nicht um effekte in diesem
psychologischen semestern um stimmungen
sind also stimmungs störung weil
verzweiflung und depression nichts
momentane sind wie gut oder eben auch
wie begierde sondern sie können
dauerhaft bleiben
wie gesagt die psychologische auffassung
von verzweiflung müssen das streng
unterscheiden von philosophischen
auffassung wie sie jetzt hier entwickelt
also interessant ist auch noch das
ticket verzweifelt als eine form von
fast über dir ja auch ein buch
geschrieben hat der begriff angst wir
gehen aber hier nochmal jetzt zusammen
sind auf martin heideggers tierische
angst ein
das ist nur noch mal hat sich ganz stark
angelehnt und er thematisiert jetzt die
angst im rahmen seiner foto mental und
elo gibt es da seid also hier müssen wir
jetzt das dasein verstehen um die angst
verstehen zu können ist ähnlich wie bei
kik gehört dass selbst das in diesen
verschiedenen redaktionen verstricken
ist so könnte man auch ganz ähnlich das
dasein versteht nachhaltiger die angst
ist eine grund befindlichkeit des
daseins unterscheidet auch zwischen
angst und furcht die furcht hat ein
bisschen was ihr effektives während die
das immer ganz konkret gerichtet während
die angst ja eine form von fast schon
metaphysische einstellung ist dies
völlig unbestimmt und an alles in der
welt wird belanglos hier hatten wir auch
eine schöne parallele zur es betrifft
des nickels den er natürlich
nachhaltiger gilt hatte zehn jahren
nachhinein aber auch kickers bedürfte
verzweiflung und wie immer haben diese
emotionen eine gewisse ambivalenz
eingeschrieben das ist auch noch ein
wichtiger zug den wir feststellen können
emotionen sind nie immer eindeutig seien
sie changieren zwischen der positiven
kommunikation einen negativen und so ist
es auch mit der angst die uns nämlich
trotz dieser bedrückung auch etwas
erschließen lässt nämlich dass sein zum
sein können als freizeit es sich werfens
wenn uns die welt leben verschwindet in
der angst dann kriegen wir den blick
fürs wesentliche
so argumentiert heiliger dann haben uns
noch der neid und eifersucht und anderes
todes gewidmet hier hatten wir ein
schöner allegorie von peter beucke wo
wir einige detail beobachtung machen
konnten natürlich konnten wir lange
nicht dieses ganze die ganze metaphorik
und allegorie wir schließen
der neid besteht nicht darin dass eine
personal der andere
um ein bestimmtes gut c beneidet weil
sie dieses gerne hätte das greift zu
kurz der bekommt die problematik
vielmehr der neid dadurch dass die
neidische personal gründe sucht und auch
scheinbar zumindest findet welche person
bewilligen 10 an schlechtem licht zeigen
so dass e10 nicht verdient also das ist
dann die missgunst
diese suche nach möglichen gründen zeigt
dass ihm leid viel destruktive
überlegungen spielen wie aristoteles
richtig bemerkt findet nicht nur da
statt wo es eine basis für vergleiche
gibt personen die sich in sehr
verschiedenen positionen befinden werden
dann das seltener beneiden als solche
die ähnlich gestützt und das finde ich
eine ganz wichtige einsicht von
aristoteles neid setzt immer
vergleichsmöglichkeiten zu hause
diese vergleichsmöglichkeiten deuten
wieder darauf hin dass in eine ganz
starke urteils dimension enthalten ist
weil immer wieder verglichen wird immer
wieder beurteilt wird immer wieder
gemessen wird und das kann natürlich nur
durch einsetzte vernunft kognitiv
erfolgen je hatten wir noch am ende so
eine gewisse beziehung zur eifersucht
entdeckt und in der eifersucht finden
sich strategien eine andere person ein
schlechtes licht zu rücken um die kunst
anbieten person zu werden
auch hier haben wir im vergleich arbeit
dass wir zum beispiel auch noch
interessantes hausarbeit thema neid
abzugrenzen von der eifersucht darauf
kommen dabei noch zehn am ende genau zu
sprechen dann sind wir wieder auf sat 1
gegangen diesmal aber auf seine griff
des hasses in seiner haupt
philosophische schrift dass sein dass
nichts also auch hier wieder wieder
ekeln so wird auch der hardware als
existenz philosophischer sicht
betrachtet der hass gibt intentional
nicht einer bestimmten eigenschaft einer
anderen person hat die existenz dieser
an pro person als solchen ja mal wieder
die existenz begriff drin
der hass konnte darin dass der andere
uns in seiner freiheit überschreitet und
vergeben ständig vater spricht hier von
einer transzendenz wir werden durch die
andere person sofern sie frei ist immer
wieder über schritten sozusagen weil sie
eben uns nicht nur als gegenstand
gegeben als dies nicht
gegenstück wir tun vielmehr ein
gegenstand von ihr zur wehr
das ist eine tendenz die nachsaat den
hass reduziert ich finde hier eine
schöne metaphorik es ist ein schwarzes
gefühl das finde ich auch etwas ganz
destruktives aber wir müssen nach satu
im haus den anderen obwohl wir ihn
vernichten wollen gerade auch anerkennen
das könnte eine gewisse dialektik nennt
die an die ethische herr knecht die
elektrik erinnert dann zimmer zu der
positiven gegen emotionen des hasses
kommen zu lieber erstmal an von
augustinus aber auch von einer abend der
jungen hatten ihre dissertation die
liebe hatten wieder ein systematisch
unabhängig von biden gesagt darf als
eine art von emotion oppositions
emotionen zum hass gelten
dann hatten wir gesehen dass die liebe
eine gewisse analogie zum effekt der
begierde hat wie auch der hass eine ag
zum effekt der hut und haben hatte in
ihrer 1929 erschien dissertation diesen
liebes begriff bei augustinus besonders
untersucht den amor den begriff als
überbegriff verwendet und eben hier zwei
formen unterschieden einmal die kita ist
das ist der armor der das weltliche
endlich sich richtet und einmal die
caritas die sich auf das unvergängliche
wichtig diese uneigennützige liebe ganz
am ende der letzten sitzung haben uns
abschließend noch mit refrain des liedes
begriff befasst so sieht der gute herr
aus er vertritt die these dass liebe
eine form von autonomie ist und eine
besondere art von verbindlichkeit
darstellt die willentliche notwendigkeit
nicht löschen eines city hier ist man
erst mal erstaunt es ging doch paradox
wie können wir dann in der liebe autonom
oder auch frei seien häufig zwar der
auffassung liebe sein zustand wo man
nicht mehr ganz bei sinnen ist wo man
ihr unfrei ist ganz klar wenn der
effekte hier muss man eben wieder
unterscheiden
liebe von begierde oder bloß
perfekten liebe versteht frame für geben
als ein wesentliches phänomen als eine
form von zuneigung die ihn motiviert ist
durch unsere individualität im gegensatz
zu kants begriff der moralischen
verbindlichkeit die laut frankfurt eine
logische notwendigkeit bezeichnet
denken sie an die frage meinungsforscher
des kategorischen imperativ sie geht es
um logische widerspruchsfreiheit da geht
es in der verbindlichkeit der liebe nach
freund wird nicht um diesen
metaphysische logische notwendigkeit
seine kontingente notwendigkeit die uns
als individuen trifft und deswegen eben
auch kontingent ist und nicht allgemein
ist also nach kanntest jede form von
kontingenten individualität die bei der
wild bestimmung eine rolle spielt eine
wand hätte gummi oder das was jetzt
frankfurt unter liebe bestimmt würde
nach kann keineswegs als autonomie
gelten dürfen und dagegen argumentiert
frankfurt sie betrifft nun sind
individuell wählen und unser
individuelles personales wesen der liebe
zeigen wir uns als individuen als
wesentliche frei geschöpfe nicht sehr
interessante these und auch hier kann
man trefflich einem hause beim schreiben
das war es dann gewesen
in unserem parforce ritt durch die ganze
geschichte der philosophie und ich bin
der auch hiermit erstmals zusammen
fassen ich wünsche anzuschauen auf
youtube auf fast alles gute und schöne
und produktive semesterferien